[Applaudissements]
mais selon une crypte où pas louper sai
baba sur site un creux soit ton canapé
et vient entre mourir n'est pas certain
[Musique]
c'est m
c'est elle
m
[Applaudissements]
p
web le shérif merci d'être là c'est la
famille qui a gagné le ski à vie adrian
nous a fait une chanson il est
exceptionnel on est tombé dessus ce
week-end franchement on a kiffé dos ils
sont même pas qu'ils voulaient voir le
clip ou bah ouais c'est là même la
chanson je la kiffe d'où je me demande
ça va pas devenir le générique de tout
ce que vous voulez que ça domaine
générique de tous par au poste oui oui
non non d'accord
[Applaudissements]
c'est papa sur titres agresso at on
qualifié
[Musique]
d'infos médias entre morez de sorte que
ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]